[Music]
all right now performing D featuring
Manuel toriso give it up for sha Paul
everybody Liv
SCS Kelly CL
the hey
[Music]
yuel
all to me like blood on you about to be
the number one being on my world baby
girl you know I'm saying attaching me
like B and chain move that body that's
suing on my brain of the energy the way
that I free baby girl get the fire
[Music]
flame
baby
[Music]
hey yo it's SC you know it's K clock
show yeah man man up yourself
go one more time y'all let's hear it for
sha Paul and Manuel
Tero this single in come day is
available for download now yall got to
go get it we'll be right back with I'm
[Music]
like
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home